[Applaudissements]
pour commencer je voulais commencer par
présenter de différentes manières en
mettant plus en avant mon identité
ma famille mes hobbies ou encore mon
parcours scolaire mais dans aucune des
versions cette présentation
j'ai oublié de mentionner même si cela
se voit déjà que chez un handicap
ça tombe bien je ne veux pas le cacher
d'autant plus que pour aujourd'hui en
tout cas ces appels à descendre à
présent suffit donc pourquoi on dit café
mais on vit heureuse car c'est ce que je
suis handicapé quand je suis né
prématuré à six mois seulement
pour faire simple et éviter les termes
médicaux compliqué
le fait que je sois ni trop tôt ni d'une
palissade mon corps le temps de se
développer plus le traumatisme de la
naissance a provoqué un bug qui sait que
la partie de moi c'est bon ça c'est
commander les informations de ma tête et
mes jambes ne le fait pas ou très mal
j'ai donc à logicoop voltaire qui
m'empêche de marché on vit quand j'ai la
chance de l'être
malheureusement tous les enfants ni trop
tôt ne sont pas là pour le dire - oui et
réseaux 6 kg une famille et des amis qui
malgré les obstacles et les difficultés
sont toujours là pour moi et même s'il
ya eu des moments de tristesse et de
déception
je ne me rappelle pas m'être sentie
malheureuse à cause de mon handicap
pourtant j'ai pu constater avec le temps
et les différents regards et des accents
déjà que certaines personnes pensaient
que handicap et virus serait
incompatible
j'ai souvent des réactions comme et et
des feuilletons des c'est bien ce que tu
fais ou encore des regards compatissants
alors la plupart du temps ces réactions
ne sont pas méchantes
elle n'en restait pas moins gênantes
voire déstabilisante
imaginez-vous juste handicap ou pas
quelqu'un que vous ne connaissez
absolument faux j'ai vu votre vie pas
désagréable non
j'ai d'ailleurs une anecdote à ce sujet
un jour je vais au supermarché cher mes
courses fis gide à la caisse devant moi
l'homme qui me voit et me regarde et me
sourit
par habitude je souris je passe à la
caisse paye mes achats et il est
toujours là à me regarder puis sortent
une nulle part il vient vers moi et me
dit tu sais dans l'autre monde this la
grille et tout ira mieux
ne t'inquiète pas waouh je me suis dit
qui est cet homme
pourquoi ce qui me parle comme ça et qu
est-ce qui ramenait au juste alors dans
une certaine mesure moins intrusive je
peux comprendre ses réactions
oui ils handicapent et une différence et
comme toute différence elle fait peur ou
du moins at ligue et pousse à des
jugements facile et rapide
je pense d'ailleurs que c'est l'un des
fondements des problèmes de notre
société comme le racisme l'homophobie ou
tout de suite d'intolérance mais je
pense aussi que ça fait exception nous
pouvons tout changer notre vision des
choses
pour cela il suffit de comprendre et de
s'informer
c'est pourquoi on partage aujourd'hui
mon expérience de vie et mes croyances
j'espère pouvoir vous faire comprendre
que même avec une différence la vie peut
être le dell
cependant il existe différents types de
handicap plus ou moins lourds et
toujours partant du principe que je ne
peux juger que ce que je connais je ne
fais référence ici qu'à man next et
l'ancien handicap
chacun est donc libre de se reconnaître
dans certaines situations et d'être
d'accord ou pas avec ce que je partage
donc oui j'ai un handicap
et oui le quotidien est toujours un peu
plus compliqué ne pas pouvoir aller
librement en ville au cinéma ou à la
plage savait pas si des obstacles pour
les qualifs se battre un peu tous les
jours accepter qu'il y ait des choses
que tu ne pourras jamais c'est comme
courir marcher danser sauter deux jambes
ça fait partie des difficultés et c'est
peut-être là la partie la plus
compliquée mais avez vous tué déjà
partir loin par amour loin de chez vous
ou encore vous habituer à la vie sans
admettre que vous aimiez si vous tous
dans laquelle vous pouvez trouver un
exemple quand pas d'âge et qui colle à
votre vie alors vous savez ce que c'est
que de devoir s'adapter mois avec un
handicap
j'ai eu une enfance joyeuse j'ai joué
grandi dans une garderie qui ne m'a
jamais fait ressortir mon handicap je
suis ouvert la tête deux fois et j'ai
reçu des fessées
non pas parce que j'avais un handicap
mais juste parce que j'étais une enfant
qui n'écoutaient pas autre chose que ses
valises et j'ai fait du bouquet avec mon
papa et geforce les parages été déjoué
que je finissais barca c'est une semaine
entre eux mais j'ai aussi été scolarisés
dans des établissements ordinaires
il y avait donc ceux qui se moquaient de
mon handicap
il se faut qu'ils la seule différence
est et qu'il pouvait pousser mon
fauteuil dans la cool j'ai beaucoup été
quand on le cher mais le handicap
mais comme dans toute situation
l'école est souvent le lieu des mots
clés pour moi c'était le handicap pour
d'autres c'était le fois les lunettes ce
appareil doté
enfin mauvaise que je veux dire il y a
toujours quelque chose
mais pour éviter cela je vous invite à
ne pas hésiter à expliquer la différence
aux enfants il contient le diable
jusqu'à ce que l'on croit pour ma part
et parce que j'ai la chance d'être
entouré de petits cousins cousines mien
sifflet ils m'ont déjà tous demandé
pourquoi j'étais en faute et
généralement ça commence à trois ou
quatre ans je la des ponts alors que
c'est parce que je suis sorti trop tôt
du monde m'a vraiment que j'aime
beaucoup et que je ne peux pas marcher à
cette explication ils me regardent
souris et s'en vont ok satisfait de la
réponse
plus tard ils me demanderont peut-être
encore pourquoi je suis en fauteuil et
je trouverai d'autres mots pour leur
expliquer mais en attendant il joue avec
mon fauteuil
et pour eux il n'y a rien de grave bref
tout ça pour vous dire que j'ai
peut-être une l'enfance comparable à la
vôtre appelé tous
j'ai joué grandi et je me suis adapté
pourtant le handicap mais aussi vive
c'est vivre des expériences uniques pour
exemple en 2004 à l'âge de 13 ans je
suis pas champion ce qu'on a trois mois
pour une opération et de la ride et de
la rééducation
c'était le choc des cultures et des
modes de vie mois le bébé de mes parents
je devais apprendre à vivre la semaine
sans papa ou maman et c'est à ce
moment-là que j'ai un peu grandi
être entourés d'enfants ou handicap
différent il y avait des handicaps des
naissances comme moi ou des handicaps
acquis à cause d'accidents notamment
puis il y avait surtout ce garçon qui
lui ne pouvait ni parler ni marcher ni
voir il est et restera une position
allongée et on le voyait qu'au moment de
jeu ou au repas donc pendant pendant les
fêtes de fin d'année ce qu'il pouvait
quitter le centre pour aller avec le
parent ce que j'ai fait mais avant de
partir j'ai entendu ce gars ont poussé
un cri et ce sont chez moi à parler
encore longtemps
c'était pour moi un clip de tristesse et
j'ai toujours pensé que c'était parce
qu'il sentait que tout le monde ça
allait et que lui ne le pouvait pas et
c'est à ce moment là plus inconsciemment
ou consciemment que je me suis dit moi
j'ai la chance de pouvoir partir et de
profiter et c'est ce que je vais faire
cette expérience m'a fait mûrir et
comprendre que même avec mon handicap
j'ai la chance d'avoir tout ce que j'ai
et de pouvoir faire tout ce que je fais
alors oui je te va marcher sur la plage
pour aller jusqu'à la mer d'un croyez
moi je fais descendre sur les fesses
double dose ça vous y arrivez des
escaliers pour aller quelque part avec
les bonnes personnes pour lever des je
te peut-être y arriver je ne peux pas
aller en ville tout seul je le fais avec
des amis qui voit au delà du handicap et
qui m'aident tout simplement
alors bien sûr tout ça ne m'empêche pas
d'agir pour une société plus accessible
mais le handicap veut aussi dire
peut-être être un peu plus conscience de
ses limites
et lorsqu'un obstacle me paraît
impossible
je les accepte et passe à autre chose là
encore voir le verre à moitié plein
c'est un jeu une gymnastique de l'esprit
qui permet d'avoir plus ou moins le
soulier je vous invite tous à essayer ça
peut paraître philosophique est innocent
mais dans ce monde de fous ça fait
vraiment du bien alors mon message
aujourd'hui série peu importe les
situations et même si c'est quelquefois
compliqué parce que nous ne sommes pas
penchés essayant de comprendre et de
connaître avant de juger qu'elle nous
pouvons toujours l'avoir dûment
l'entreprise pour ma part je suis rina
j'ai 27 ans je suis handicapé mais
tellement plus encore je suis en vie est
rude
merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]